I have in the past on this show given
John Oliver a bit of a hard time and
it's easy to give him a hard time seeing
as he is such a smarmy insufferable
little British Muppet but my biggest
issue with John Oliver isn't that he is
an annoying smug bastard it's that he's
an annoying smug bastard who thinks that
his own IQ is about 40 points higher
than it really is he makes very lame and
very trit arguments that to the
suggestable viewer pass for clever and
intelligent because he has a live
audience of trained seals applauding the
whole time also spends a lot of time
making his lame and trite arguments you
know he harps on one subject for almost
half an hour which tricks his gullible
fans into thinking that he's being
thorough they see that he has a 25
minute monologue on a certain subject
and they figure that it must be like the
definitive SmackDown on that topic
because it's 25 minutes long what they
don't realize is that he's actually just
restating the same shallow dubious
premise over and over again for 25
minutes this is how he dupes the
credulous Rubes Among Us which is a
problem because there are a lot of
credulous Rubes Among Us so when I heard
that John Oliver took on the issue of
homeschooling in one of his most recent
shows I expected his rant to be
incredibly dumb and misleading because
they always are but then I watched it
and I discovered that it's even worse
than I assumed as always with John
Oliver you'll find his monologues less
and less persuasive the more personally
knowledgeable you are about the subject
and we have been homeschooling our kids
for nearly a decade so it landed
especially flat for me but I'm going to
go through the monologue in extensive
detail so that you can hear it for
yourself unlike John Oliver I don't
believe in cherry-picking so we're going
to go through this now Oliver's basic
position is that there isn't enough
regulation on homeschooling parents he
insists that a large number of us are
abusive and negligent and stupid and we
need greater oversight to make sure that
we are teaching our children in a way
that the state finds acceptable actually
John Oliver wants to make sure that
we're teaching our children a way that
John Oliver finds acceptable but it just
so happens that John Oliver views and
priorities are indistinguishable from
the states he has paid millions of
dollars a year to say things on camera
yet he never says anything that any
generic bureaucrat wouldn't say he just
uses a little bit more profanity when he
says it don't take it from me though um
let's dive in watch we're going to talk
about homeschooling during the pandemic
many parents were suddenly forced to do
it and while some struggled others like
this family absolutely thrived a b c d e
f g h i j k l m n o p q r s t u v WX y
and z now you know your
ABC that is clearly excellent but it's
also it is also a pretty mean way to
make other parents look like
total okay now now this is how Oliver
Begins the segment he gives props to
some homeschooling parents so that he is
licensed to spend the next 20 minutes
accusing the rest of us of being Nazis
and child abusers but keep in mind that
this is what Oliver considers to be
clearly excellent homeschooling shooting
a Tik Tock video of your kids dancing to
an ABC rap when at least four of those
kids are obviously way too old to still
be reviewing the ABCs at all is what
qualifies as homeschooling so
magnificent John Oliver says that it
makes other parents quote feel
like that's something to remember as
Oliver begins giving examples of what in
his mind qualify as laughably awful
homeschooling also
you know if you're the cynical type you
may have already noted that Oliver's
example of good homeschooling comes from
a black family and you might say to
yourself well of course yeah that's
that's what he would do and yes you're
right that is totally intentional
throughout the monologue he gives three
examples of sympathetic homeschool
families and they're all black um all
the examples of bad homeschoolers on the
other hand are white that is how utterly
predictable and contrived all of this is
with that let's continue and you may
have heard a stereotype of homeschoolers
being Christian conservatives who object
to what kids learn in public school
environments and I admit those people do
exist take this man who offers this
pretty shaky rationalization for pulling
his kid out of school I think the type
of content on what they're teaching
about sex or anal sex that my third
grade daughter should not be in a
classroom where a teacher or someone
else is teaching her about that and that
was your experience in school I threw
through friends in other spots that had
been kids at those ages cuz mine was
only in first grade when we were pulled
well that sounds like
total although I guess I do basically
agree with him there things that are
definitely not happening should continue
not to happen now here we have of course
a patented John Oliver tactic which is
scoffing in place of an actual argument
this is all Oliver will do to even
acknowledge the concerns over sexual
sexually inappropriate subject matter in
public school despite the fact that
these concerns are a major primary
driving force behind the growth of
homeschooling so you would think that he
would spend a little bit more time on it
but Oliver simply declares that all of
those concerns are quote total and moves
on you notice what he doesn't do he
doesn't go into any specific detail or
any detail at all about the actual
content of public school comprehensive
sexed curricula you know he doesn't say
that's here's what sex head classes are
really teaching he doesn't do that
because he knows that if he provided
that kind of context it would undercut
his point instead of proving it he knows
that there are a great many sex said
courses in public schools like the one
co-sponsored by Planned Parenthood for
kids aged 11 to 13 and recently
highlighted by the daily signal that
among other things lists among its
course objectives that it wants to quote
normalize
masturbation now John Oliver doesn't
want to say hey you dumb parents take it
easy all the schools want to do is talk
to your 11y year old about
masturbation he doesn't want to say that
so he doesn't say it but that's
essentially his message there are of
course a great many specific examples
like this of comprehensive sexed classes
in high school middle school and even
even Elementary School that cover all
kinds of sexually explicit topics that
no sane parent wants some strange adult
talking to their kids about there are
also the pornographic books that are
offered to students in schools all
across the country books like gender
queer uh and that's a book that
discusses and shows images of oral sex
masturbation sex toys Etc and you don't
have to take it from me that gender
queer is in schools all around the
country take it from the leftists who
have conniption fits and start screaming
about book burning if you try to remove
that book and those like it from the
classroom speaking of which Ronda santis
banned lessons about gender identity and
sexuality for kids in prek through third
grade and the left again exploded with
rage John Oliver says that it's total
that any schools are teaching those
kinds of subjects to kids that young
well if that's the case then why did his
own side cry out in horror when Des
santis ban discussions that Oliver
claims aren't happening
anyway now these are questions that
Oliver doesn't want you to
ask instead you just clap along and
laugh at his crappy jokes and don't
think too deeply about any of
it the ceiling of how good homeschooling
can be is admittedly very high but the
flaw of how bad it can get is basically
non-existent because to an extent that
you may not realize in many parts of the
country homeschooling is essentially
unregulated which can result in enormous
damage so given that tonight let's take
a look at homeschooling and let's start
with the fact there is a lot that we
don't know about homeschooled kids from
exactly how many there are to what they
are learning when I said there are
around 2 million of them the reason
that's an estimate is that depending on
the state homeschool families might not
have to report what they are doing at
all in these 26 States parents simply
have to file a notice once a year with
officials to let let them know that they
are homeschooling their child in these
13 they only have to file a notice once
with no requirement to check in ever
again and in the remaining 11 they don't
have to notify anyone at all oh dear God
can you imagine the horror you mean to
tell me there are potentially millions
of parents out there who are you know
talking to their kids and teaching them
and guiding them and telling them things
without providing the state and John
Oliver with a full written account of
everything they're saying I mean it's
almost like these families believe they
should have privacy and
self-determination and freedom how
presumptuous of them how dare they you
can't just go teaching stuff to your own
children especially if you haven't
cleared it with John Oliver yet John
Oliver will decide what you're allowed
to say to your own kids in your own home
thank you very much after all as he
argues many of these parents are
providing inadequate educations to their
children here is one parent
enthusiastically explaining how he
taught his kids science I can't tell you
how many times um you know in my home in
our kitchen table we've dissected you
know sheep eyeballs or frogs uh kitchen
kitchens are great labs for this kind of
thing so they'll getbody get a sheep
eyeball well John you just Google sheep
eyeball for homeschoolers lots of people
absolutely okay first are kitchens the
best lab for this kind of thing I think
probably labs are the best lab for this
kind of thing I'm just like maybe don't
go dissecting sheep eyeballs in the same
place where you cut Oles for
salad yeah you idiot homeschoolers I
mean don't cut into the carcasses of
dead animals in your kitchen John Oliver
would never do that which I guess means
he's never made any meat dish at all in
his life I mean I've cut into the raw
flesh of cows chickens pigs deer turkey
other animals in my kitchen I didn't
realize the kitchen was a place just for
slicing olives you dork now I will say
that I I certainly won't be accepting
any dinner invitations from John Oliver
first because I'll never receive one
second because he's a apparently a
vegetarian and third uh because he
evidently doesn't realize that you can
use soap to disinfect your cooking
surfaces but the real point is that
Oliver is inviting us to laugh at a
homeschool dad who's obviously going to
Great Lengths to provide a very thorough
scientific education to his children
like this should be an example of one of
the good
homeschoolers but this is Oliver's
example of a bad homeschool education
the ABC rap was a good
example but this guy who's doing a diss
with his with his you know actual
biology classes with his uh with his
kids that's that's a bad
example if you needed more evidence that
this guy is a clown who shouldn't be
taken even remotely seriously well there
you go you know you heard me talk about
how important it is to have a VPN to
protect your online privacy but choosing
a VPN you trust is equally as important
I can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
here's why Express VPN doesn't log your
online activity lots of cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data at
advertisers but expressvpn doesn't do
this they even developed a technology
called trusted server that makes their
VPN servers incapable of storing any
data at all expressvpn also now uses
lightwe a new VPN protocol they engineer
to make user speeds faster than ever
expressvpn is so easy to use you don't
need any technical skills to get set up
just fire up the app tap one button to
connect and that's it even your
grandparents could do it even I can do
it that's how easy it is protect
yourself with the VPN that I use and
Trust at expressvpn.com slatwall show
use my L expressvpn.com walow to get
three extra months free that's exp rsvpn
docomo somehow it gets
worse it is absolutely a parents right
to educate their child with religion if
they so choose but the quality of some
of these books can be troubling for
instance one current ABCA history book
says that the beginning of the 20th
century witnessed a cultural breakdown
that threatened to destroy the very
roots of Western Civilization the cause
of of this dissolution was an idea or
philosophy known as liberalism meanwhile
a workbook from AC celebrates the
confederate general Robert ele as a
devoted Christian who practiced his
Christianity in all his dealings with
others uh yes what's your point both of
those statements are true at the very
least they are intellectually defensible
perspectives but Oliver again simply
scoffs at them and in the process
inadvertently proves why homeschooling
is so important in the first place
he believes it is an objective and
self-evident fact that liberalism has
been an unquestioned Force for good in
the world that and that Confederates
were all cartoon villains fighting for
nothing more than the continued
subjugation of black people he's not
even smart or introspective enough to
realize that his views on that on those
topics are subjective so when his
subjective views are taught as fact in
public school and they are he sees no
legitimate reason for anyone to object
indeed anyone who does object is
obviously a Nazi and he makes that
connection
explicit even that is a preferable
alternative to the single worst
homeschool curriculum that we found
whose creators excitedly promoted it on
a podcast we are so deeply invested into
making sure that that child becomes a
wonderful
Nazi and by homeschooling we're going to
get that done well that is terrifying
now you should know that Oliver actually
lingers on these Nazi homeschoolers for
multiple minutes he dedicates a sizable
chunk of his monologue to this podcast
nobody's ever heard of or listened to
and this one random wack job who
represents at most maybe I don't know
0.00000000 1% of homeschoolers if that
many he can't begin to engage with the
actual Arguments for homeschooling the
reason that the the vast majority of
homeschool parents would actually give
so instead he draws our attention to the
most outlandish obscure outlier he can
possibly find now Oliver may be a
pedestrian midwit but he certainly at
least realizes that the number of
homeschool parents who want to turn
their kids into quote wonderful Nazis is
not large enough to fill a school bus
much less warrant a mention during this
segment but he throws them in there
anyway as a means to of of blatant
emotional manipulation and to set the
stage for this deregulating homeschool
in doesn't just eliminate safeguards
against parents who are bad teachers it
also eliminates them against parents who
are bad people for all the hsld DA's
talk of parental rights it's worth
remembering Elon Musk is a parent OJ
Simpson is a parent Darth Vader is such
a parent he made it part of his fancy
name change the point is having a child
does not inherently make you virtuous
and one of the key problems here is
child welfare laws were written before
homeschooling was legal in all 50 states
so they rely heavily on the premise that
a child is going to be in school and
seen by other
adults yeah Elon Musk is a parent I mean
you wouldn't want Elon Musk teaching you
wouldn't want a guy who's building
rocket ships going into space teaching
your your kids right obviously a third
grade science teacher is better equipped
than Elon Musk to teach science
obviously so there it is homeschool is a
cover for child abusers he contends uh
many hom School parents are using
homeschool to hide the abuse they're
inflicting on their children because of
this he argues there should be all
manner of Regulation and monitoring and
background checks imposed on all parents
who wish to educate their own children
he he says that we should all be um
screened for red flags among other
measures now it's true of course that
some parents are scumbags who abuse
their kids it would follow that a
certain portion of those scumbags a
small minority are probably
homeschoolers but it does not follow
that all parents who homeschool should
therefore be treated as suspected child
abusers you know homeschool aside the
sad reality is that a certain portion of
parents will use the physical privacy of
their homes as a forum for inflicting
all manner of abuse on their children
but it doesn't follow that all families
who insist on privacy in their homes
should be treated as
suspicious nor does it mean that locking
your front door is a red flag indicating
that you're likely abusing your children
now I acknowledge that a minority of
awful parents do terrible things to
their kids but I will not tolerate the
state treating me like I'm one of those
parents when I'm not see this is not a
hard concept to understand or at least
it shouldn't
be besides John the abuse problem Cuts
both ways yes some parents are abusive
also some teachers are abusive not just
some many in fact the department of
education's own study on this subject
found that one in 10 public school
students are targets of sexual
misconduct by School staff one in 10
that is the Department of Education that
is their number not mine that works out
to millions of victims at
school now Oliver says that school is a
safeguard against abuse but forgets to
mention that for millions of children
school is the place where the abuse
occurs now this is a common theme he
talks about the failures and pitfalls of
homeschooling but never acknowledges any
of the failures and pitfalls of public
schooling he tells us about what he
considers to be the poor education
provided by homeschool parents but
doesn't say anything about the fact that
large percentage of public school kids
aren't learning learning much at all a
recent report in the Scientific American
revealed that two-thirds of kids in this
country most of them public schooled
can't read fluently according to the na
only a third of eighth graders are
proficient in Reading in other subject
the the picture is even more Grim it's
well known that a significant
preponderance of American adults are
shockingly ignorant about about
geography history Civics not to mention
Math and Science most adults today were
public schooled and yet nobody would
deny that we're surrounded by
morons I mean the proof is all around us
look at the poll released this summer
finding that 40% of Americans don't even
know why we celebrate July 4th for
instance and we could go on and on with
examples like this it's the world that
public school has
created and this is another major reason
why parents are pulling their kids out
of the system because the system is
failing in its basic responsibility to
actually educate the next generation of
Americans Oliver doesn't grapple with
that doesn't even so much as acknowledge
it instead he says this the fact is
Teachers serve multiple functions at
school in addition to education they
watch out for signs of abuse they
chaperone school events and they pretend
not to know why Ellie won't sit next to
Rachel Rachel won't sit next to Kelsey
Kelsey's not talking to Ethan even
though Ethan's having a joint birthday
party with with Kelsey's brother Bryce
who just happens to be Rachel's
boyfriend since last period and they do
all of that while also trying to teach
long division teachers are superheroes
who should make a million dollars a
year there you go homeschool parents are
Nazi child abusers and public school
teachers are superheroes never mind that
they're churning out millions of kids
who can't read or perform basic
arithmetic or point to South America on
a map they're superheroes that's it
please clap John Oliver has once again
demonstrated that he has the intellect
ual depth of a piss tainted children's
waiting pool and we haven't even gotten
to the worst argument he makes against
homeschooling which he saves for the
very end listen in a perfect world we'd
make sure that homeschool kids were both
safe and actually receiving a functional
education and there are smaller
organizations like this one pushing for
those sort of changes but at the beest
minimum we could require in all 50
states to register a child as
homeschooled so there's at least a
record that they exist that is how low
the bar is
here yes a record that they exist
otherwise nobody would know they exist
there would be no record of the child's
existence other than the child's birth
certificate and Social Security number
and medical records and the fact that
they're claimed on your taxes and
several other forms of documentation
aside from all that aside from the fact
that your child's existence is
definitely already documented a dozen
times over aside from that you need to
report as a homeschooler to the state or
nobody will know that your child is even
a real person now Oliver makes the time
to convey this delusional concern about
homeschooling but dedicates no time at
all to honestly engaging with any of the
concerns about public schooling which is
of course how he approaches every issue
he talks about because he is a
self-satisfied pompous dishonest mush
brained prick a man who we can tell was
certainly not homeschooled himself which
is maybe the best argument for
homeschooling that I can offer and it's
also why John Oliver is today once again
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there